cyberpunk 2077 is popular again and
there are new updates on Street Fighter
6 and Tekken 8.
cyberpunk 2077 has seen a surge in
popularity recently as a recent patch
big discounts and a Netflix anime series
have all helped draw players back into
the Sci-Fi sandbox according to steam DB
and spotted by Eurogamer concurrent
players peaked yesterday at 37 000
beating other popular games such as
Elden ring Destiny 2 and Grand Theft
Auto 5 on the steam charts this is more
than double cyberpunk 2077's August high
of 16
000 players and is presumably thanks in
part to the edge Runners update that
added a substantial number of new
features and improvements cyberpunk Edge
Runners has also proven to be a big hit
on Netflix with its slick visuals and
storytelling and with the upcoming
Phantom Liberties expansion on the
horizon players have reinstalled the
game or taken advantage of a steep
discount to jump back into night City an
official modding tool has also been
released as free DLC on PC and it
includes Custom Sounds animations
scripts and more on Xbox series X and S
users can get a taste of PC controls as
keyboard and mouse support was added to
that version of the game in patch 1.6
now let's move right along to some
fighting games one day after capcom's
Tokyo game show 2022 special program
showcase new modes characters and a
closed beta test for Street Fighter 6 a
separate presentation has confirmed the
launch roster for the game through an
intro video the presentation showed the
introduction to the game's single player
story mode World Tour which showcases
the entire roster as a narrator talks
over the video all 11 confirmed
characters were shown as were seven
previously unknown Fighters the Capcom
TGs 2022 special program revealed many
of Street Fighter 6's featured modes
including the battle Hub where players
can join together and play both Street
Fighter 6 and classic Capcom games also
the aforementioned World Tour will let
players create their own avatar and
explore the world of Street Fighter
including the ability to learn moves
from members of The Game's roster and
use them in battle against NPCs
throughout the world in other fighting
game news Tekken 8's director has
revealed even more info about what we
can expect from the fighting game sequel
during an interview with IGN aside from
more exciting father versus son
showdowns Tekken 8 is built from the
ground up in unreal 5. as for the story
Tekken 8 is being considered a turning
point and the game's director promised
the story mode hasn't been shrunk from
what players saw from Tekken 7 what he
didn't say is whether or not Tekken 8
will include rage Arts as seen in Tekken
7. considering how unpopular The Raid
system and rage Arts were when they were
first implemented let me know if you
want to see them in Tekken 8 and what
you're planning on playing this weekend
foreign